et
pas de voyous de la paix
maintenant
on fait le plein de fois par jour
pourrait pas vendre des motos tranquille
il ya plus de capacité
je ne fais la foule à
[Musique]
6 mai
d'accord
parce qu'on si oui quand
oui
sur
moi
[Musique]
le verdict du procès est enfin tombée
après des semaines de procès et
plusieurs jours de discussions le jury
s'est mis d'accord l'actrice amber heard
et reconnus coupables de diffamation
contre son ex époux johnny depp elle est
condamnée à verser 15 millions de
dollars de dommages et intérêts à
l'acteur il en réclamait lui 50 millions
notamment car il considérait qu'elle lui
avait fait perdre plusieurs rôles au
cinéma pour autant johnny depp n'est pas
innocenté il est lui aussi reconnu
coupable d'avoir diffamé son ex épouse
il devra lui verser 2 millions de
dommages et intérêts soit 1.5 km est bon
oh
oui
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]